right one of my favorites it's a tangy
fruit salad and it's for breakfast would
you believe start off with a chili now
give it a little rub so here those seeds
being released get your knife and come
all the way down turn it over and just
slice it into fork and then finely chop
that chili
I want this salad slightly hot suddenly
use all the chili but 1/2 the seeds the
seeds are where the heat is so the less
you use the mulder your dish
lassi chopped next one of my favorite
pace tamarind paste this is quite tart
quite sour but it's a wonderful
complement to the sweetness of the fruit
and goes brilliantly well with a chili
Parma sugar and this is where it
sweetens up the dressing as it enriches
it then the zest and the juice of a lime
cut into quarters and then twist the
line seem maximized and all that juice
out now to finish that dressing off some
toasted peanuts get that pan nice and
hot no touch of salt
that'll help dry roast the peanuts even
quicker
make sure we get a really nice dark
color on those peanuts because it will
really transform that dressing to crush
your roasted nuts the mess free way
simply wrap them in a clean cloth and
use a rolling pin or a pan to bash them
crush that's the hard bit done now for
the fruit and here's an easy way to prep
a pineapple pineapple take off the top
take off the bottom and stand it up use
the culinary knife and follow it down
basically like shaving the pineapple
don't worry about these little spikes
they're the secret behind doing it this
way it's not losing half the pineapple
there's nothing wrong with a few Brown
bits it's all good fiber slice the
pineapple in half and then slice down
each quarter slice across and chop
delicious pineapple chunks next apples
and pears diced then to give a lovely
fresh light note deseeded cucumber I
don't want the seeds in the fruit salad
the cucumber seeds will make your baby
water in dilute the strength for that
wonderful chili in there cucumber in for
some sweetness delicious mango just
slice it nicely your dressing and just
drizzle that over the fruit salad in
secret of a good fruit salad it's not
drowning in the dressing but really
makes sure that you've got that nice
coating on all the fruits don't worry
about just having for breakfast because
this is the kind of tangy for excited
you can have for lunch a healthy snack
in the afternoon but it transforms a
traditional fruit salad into something
really delicious
spicy fruit salad with a kick of Chile
trust me is an incredible breakfast and
a guaranteed pick me up in the morning